Permíteme comenzar con una pregunta interesante.
Pausa este video e intenta averiguar cuántos de
estos bloques se muestran aquí. Muy bien,
ahora trabajaremos juntos. Es posible que
hayas notado que los he organizado de una forma
interesante: aquí tenemos bloques individuales y
vemos que hay 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9 bloques
individuales, así que escribiré 9; y luego por
aquí estos bloques se han dispuesto en estas
barras o estas pilas, donde cada pila tiene 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10 bloques, y por lo
tanto el número de barras que tenemos aquí,
ya que cada una de ellas tiene 10 bloques
individuales, nos dice cuántas decenas tenemos:
así que tenemos una decena, dos decenas y tres
decenas. Entonces, aquí puedes verlo como tres
decenas o puedes verlo como treinta bloques,
así que déjame escribirlo así: 3 decenas,
lo escribí en la posición de las decenas. Ahora,
entre estas pilas y estos bloques individuales
tenemos 3 decenas y 9, hasta ahora hemos contado
39. Y ahora, ¿qué pasa con estas cuadrículas? Bueno,
puedes notar que tienen 10 filas y 10 columnas, y
si tuvieras que contar todos los bloques en una de
estas cuadrículas verás que tiene 10 grupos de
10, que es lo mismo que 1 centena, que son: 10,
20, 30, 40, 50, 60, 70, 80, 90 y 100, así que cada
una de estas cuadrículas tiene 1 centena, y luego
¿cuántas centenas tenemos? Claramente contamos una
cuadrícula y luego otra, así que tenemos 200 aquí,
escribiré esto en el lugar de las centenas, por
lo que tenemos un total de 2 centenas, 3 decenas
y 9 unidades o 239 bloques. Ahora vamos a hacerlo
de otra forma. Permíteme mostrarte algunos bloques
y preguntarte ¿cuál de estos grupos de bloques
-está versión de color amarillo o parduzco y
esta versión de color púrpura- cuál de es la que
tiene 923 bloques. Pausa el video y ve si
puedes resolverlo. Muy bien. Entonces puede que ya
estés deduciendo que sólo tienes que ver cuántas
centenas, cuántas decenas y cuántas unidades hay,
así que veamos este amarillo. Vamos a contar estas
cuadrículas para calcular cuántas centenas hay,
tenemos: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8 y 9, así que tenemos 9
centenas, que también podríamos escribir como 900;
y luego ¿cuántas decenas tenemos? Podemos ver una,
dos, tres decenas, más 3 decenas, sumamos 30; y
luego ¿cuántas unidades tenemos? Tenemos una y
dos, así que sumamos más 2 unidades, más dos, o
podríamos decir que, en el lugar de las centenas
-permíteme poner las posiciones aquí: estas
son las centenas, estas las decenas y estas las
unidades-, en la posición de las centenas tenemos
9 centenas, en la posición de las decenas tenemos
3 decenas y en la posición de las unidades
tenemos 2 unidades, así que esto no es 923,
esto es 932. Así que probablemente será esta,
pero veamos si podemos resolverlo, y vamos a
colocarlas directamente en su posición apropiada
para que podamos ver de inmediato el resultado.
Si sólo contamos los bloques individuales, los
que no están en una barra o en una cuadrícula,
podemos ver que hay 3 unidades, así que pongamos
eso en la posición de las unidades; y luego
podemos ver que tenemos 2 barras, cada una de
ellas tiene 10 bloques, por lo que hay 2 decenas
justo aquí. Podemos escribir que en la posición
de las decenas hay 2 decenas y luego ¿cuántas
centenas tenemos? Tenemos 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8 y 9 centenas, porque
cada una de estas cuadrículas tiene 100 bloques,
así que tenemos 900 bloques, y podemos escribir
un 9 en la posición de las centenas, por lo que
esta última es otra forma de representar 923.